non c'est une idée géniale cette année
que la carte de bons clients
oui à qui tu donneras une carte de bons
clients la marina qui est vraiment une
très très bonne cliente weaving est ce
qu'on peut avoir la carte de bons
clients
qu'est ce que c'est
voilà j'ai une carte bien marqué bon
client monsieur mais sert à quoi alors
la carte de bons clients
non non c'est vous c'est planant méline
enfin la carte
excusez moi mais la ceni n'est pas une
bonne cliente enfin je pense qu'ils
brûlent à donner à marina à temps il
faisait déjà ce mois ma démission mal je
fais 4 5 me sentais les clarines âge
j'avais fait une émission avec elle son
mari au moins une fois jamais donc pas
d'accord qu'est ce que c'est une carte
de banaliser un passé grâce à cette
carte tu peux revenir ici quand tu veux
arcens sont inactivées d'accord c'est
quand même on ricane à toute une blague
de baffin
même si t'as rien donné la pierre
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qu'elle te disais là non je
dis que c'était un peu pour voir notre
carte de bons clients de lire comme l'a
fait c'est un exercice
ouais sibérie est ce qu'on peut avoir
une carte de bons clients poursuivis eux
surtout ne revient avec bd on vient vous
laissant pas ce qu'on va voir les gens
qui vont revenir
il y en a qui vont s'en servir cette
carte va là sylvie testud pompignan
c'est qu'elle est
sa carte de bons clients voilà on donne
des cartes de bons clients algériens
utilisent non non non non je suis la
valeur avec cette carte du refus c'est
moi qui est non pas que je n'aime pas
moustier qu'un sapin et je l'apprécié
mais je ne lui ai jamais donné
physiquement cette carte tu n'étais pas
là mais la vérité au québec et qui
distribue les cartes pendant que c'est
pas là sans déconner c'est le monsieur
en noir là je pense que c'est moi qui
distribue les cartes ballon rond
pourquoi il faut voter si c'est valable
ou pas - 0 50 m christine une carte de
bons clients c'est génial l'enseigné de
grands pros cette mise au point un truc
encore une carte devant clients peuvent
venir quand ils veulent comme si on
était passé comme ça mais je veux quand
même on m'offre ça moi je viens à vous
autres très très bien vous venez parler
de votre livre oui tout à fait le havre
qui se termine a nommé
ça vous il n'y a pas de problème vous
venez quand vous voulez c'est sa maman
gérard sa maman bébé vient il à sa carte
de bons clients oui elle est là alors
dans qui vient quand ils veulent et un
bon voilà faut faire comment on va voir
ça c'est le copain de la voir que c'est
ma fille qui la donne bon ben voilà
c'est moi qui les donnent laurent faut
qu'on se parle
oui y'a rien de grave il n'y avait rien
gras jus revenir pour le pas si petit
que ça tu peux lui parler normal pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10
tubes abonnez vous y mettez un peu de
bleu